slate comes out quote
non-violence is an important tool for
protests
but so is violence they tweeted that out
june 4th 2020 this was during blm
non-violence is an important tool for
protests but so is violence
imagine if the daily wire the next day
tweeted out you know non-violence is
good for the make america great again
movement
but violence is important too should
have taken a few more podiums
should have smashed a few more windows
maybe worse
that would be the equivalent slate still
has its twitter account
if the daily wire ever tweeted anything
like that i assure you not only would
our social media accounts be gone
our web hosting would be gone too the
president tweets out be peaceful they
take away his twitter account
and facebook access other leftist cnn's
rizza aslan
who is actually a cannibal he's actually
eaten human brains
that's the kind of person they put on
cnn he tweets that quote if they even
try to replace rbg we burn the entire
effing thing down
i don't need to point out what would
happen if a right winger said something
similar
emmett macfarlane who's some blue check
mark on the left i don't even know what
he does
burn congress down before letting trump
try to appoint anyone to the supreme
court
laura bassett same thing if mcconnell
jams someone through which he will there
will be riots okay well there were i
guess
charlotte climber who is this
transgender fellow
who is very vocal and left-wing
we're now walking to mitch mcconnell's
house to protest so now actually going
to threaten the guy's house
obviously we chris cuomo i guess is
probably the greatest example of this
cuomo openly on national television if
you can call cnn national television
it's mostly
just an airport intercom system but
theoretically
it's a big tv network goes out and and
defends violent protests
now too many see the protests as the
problem
no the problem is what forced your
fellow citizens
to take to the streets persistent and
poisonous
inequities and injustice and please
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite
and peaceful as we have noted before the
first amendment is where it says that
protests are supposed to be peaceful
because you have the right to peaceably
assemble but i actually can't believe
i'm saying this
i want to defend chris cuomo for a
second
not defend the point he's actually
making but to defend
the thinking behind the point that he's
making
well we're all getting blue in the face
yelling about the double standards here
we are failing to acknowledge that this
is
about standards getting back to what we
were talking about earlier in the show
this is not about free speech this is
not
about censorship all societies permit
some amount of speech
and they all enforce some degree of
censorship
this has been true everywhere throughout
the entire history of the world
and it has been true in the united
states maybe particularly in the united
states
er eriopogitica which is the greatest
defense of free speech in the english
language
says that we shouldn't give free speech
to catholics and milton actually makes
some good arguments for it
john locke in his letter on toleration
says we shouldn't tolerate atheists
and he makes some good arguments for it
even the most robust
liberal defenses of free speech
acknowledged that there are limits in
censorship
what the left is saying is that if you
go out and you
you protest and it becomes violent and
use loot gucci stores
in the name of blm that is a good thing
and we will tolerate that
but if you go out and wave the american
flag and let's say it becomes
somewhat violent we will not tolerate
that
we will give blm spots at the democratic
national convention
and we will put the maga protesters in
jail and the right and certainly the
writers are going to jail
those are different standards but we've
always had standards
in the 1950s if you went out and held a
big protest
even a peaceful protest for communism
you you could be prosecuted for that
as well you should be frankly if we were
a little tougher on communism today
we might not be in the position that
we're in and if you went out then and
waved an america flag or you said
make america great again you'd be
totally fine we had standards then too
we will always have standards and what
what conservatives have
unfortunately done is we've come out and
we've said
hey i support all sorts of speech
i don't want any standards at all say
whatever words you want on television
oh drag queen story hour it's a blessing
of liberty oh it's wonderful
i would never because if i tell
you that you're not allowed to host a
drag queen story hour and have
transvestites twerk for toddlers well
then you
might tell me that i can't go to church
and so we're all just gonna throw up our
hands
because they're all the same right no no
good to go to church bad to go to dragon
queen story hour
we should encourage people to go to
church or you know practice their
religion
generally good religion though not like
uh
satanism i don't think we should promote
satanism don't think we should promote
uh
secular liberalism that's a pretty weird
religion there was just a video that
went around a new york post sent it out
of this this white woman forcing her
children to kneel down and pray
to black women actually to make an idol
out of black women actually to objectify
black women
which is kind of ironic she doesn't
think she's doing that i just thought
man secular liberalism that is a weird
religion
that is one of the strangest religions
i've ever seen but you want to promote
the good you want to discourage the bad
we've always understood this in america
conservatives libertarians
liberals all understood this well
liberals and progressives still
understand this
they still understand you got to promote
some things you got to discourage other
things
just they flip the standards right now
there's a tweet went up on january 7th
from the chinese embassy in the united
states it says quote study shows the
population change in northwest china's
zhengchang uyghur autonomous region
involves the overall
improvement in population quality oh
man an increasing number of youths chose
to spend more time and energy on
personal development
population change and population
improvement
this is an open call by an enemy nation
for genocide open promotion of genocide
on twitter
totally fine that's okay according to
the new standards
but the duly elected sitting president
of the united states
calling for peace not permitted on
twitter
or are we going to say well i can't take
a side we can't promote one over the
other
we need to support every single view
viewpoint neutrality
we're going to say that uh it doesn't
seem to be working well in practice
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video